c'erano una volta un uomo gay una donna
del sud due uomini etero bianchi che
jenner che per facilitarci chiameremo lo
stronzo alla di spa teresa un avvocato
non biodegradabile e di manuale
l'autista col cambio manuale
quest'anno carichi di rancore i nostri
eroi porteranno il loro blocco man on
the road da trieste in giù che il
viaggio abbia inizio
[Musica]
nelle estremità sud orientale e friuli
venezia giulia tra il mare adriatico e
la slovenia
sorge la preziosa trieste da molti
definita la piccola di enna sul mare
elegante e signorile grazie ai suoi
caffè storici e culla della prima
manifestazione globale che capita
trieste non può non visitare piazza
unità il borgo tari siano il castello
miramare e numerosi vicoli pieni di
vomito di gente ubriaca
perché si sa se vuoi essere un vero
tristi di vivere scopare bestemmiare
come giuda ma ciò che rende davvero
unico questo posto e il suolo costa e
rilassante la natura fa schiuma ma non è
saponi lavora
signore e signori
solo per voi
trieste
questo è il teatro romano falegname
posso dire una cosa respirate però qua
prendiamo un po di una bella boccata
d'aria al teatro romano
che maiale carbonate che continua a
respirare è proprio roma allora è
manuale come trovi questo teatro
immagine di quando lo stava l'ha
costruita di vecchietti al cantiere
attento non era già marchio sta andando
in giro col giornale
sono solo un pochino triste perché
queste cose qua che siamo degli enormi
cosi supermario dove infili dentro qua
dentro mettono tutti alberi svariati
troppo presto e quindi ci sono altre
interamente il tuo di natale
acqua dentro c'entra qualcuno l'anno non
lo so eviterei di farlo 3ds il [ __ ]
che si lancia dentro sta cosa ubriaco da
arrestare iamm trieste ciano i romani
che si infilano dentro i tombini
vi ancora
senti cominciamo a giro alla città
tanta merda passare sempre col verde
ragazzi
di ballo di farlo quando diciamo di
ballo
[Musica]
mi piacerebbe molto in lampade di tipo
questo da cui poter attraversare lo
scopo che soddisfacente
tutta l'unione io non so se voi avete
provato a sollevare questi sono piccoli
ma vi assicuro che serve la forza di
cento uomini verso levarne uno deve
farvi capire
già marco von ah bè qui a qualcosa c'è
monti
e marco quello aquila ha lasciato cadere
nella sua altra valle già masini caso
nasce la procura
andiamo a prenderci un redditi
[Musica]
e michela uno studio che si fa prima del
pranzo io sono impaziente voi attaccarlo
ministra svizzera sono sempre il giorno
di più se in fondo alla catena
alimentare
il continuo a pensare a quello che
enrico che notissimo faccia insomma che
palle dentro nipote
molto forti come ritrovi il menu mano
questa cosa che sembra parmigiano
grattugiato e rapano con te ne prendi un
pochino non molti sulla carta non sbatti
milano senna per essa il rafano tipo di
wasabi l'evento assaggiati crauti e non
sono una manna
stavo per dire la stessa cosa mi piace
molto
a milano attimi studiano nella tana
agghiaccianti gradito franzoni
nella stanza il fabbisogno calorico di
un mese loro se lo fanno alla mattina
che cos'è secondo voi l'orto un
lapidario mai che penso passi 600 5 7 8
9 e 20 21 dritto non ti sento alto la
voce ferma su 83 ma sappiamo che cosa
fare non vorrei fare altri passi
lo dice 120 punti tanto ai dati da
gigante sbagliato ma magari di passetti
presente quelle delle signore
gli arti colpacci anno i triestini e
stata cosi mike antezza
ma questo è il tuo massimo io penso che
la porta avanti
ma non sto facendo non è stato certo
sessuale di cose mila a scendere muoio
gravi
se ci metti una s di anche un'altra
parola boras pensavo buon ora
ho detto barak
e borsa
anche avevamo bisogno di viaggiare
avevo bisogno di guardare la nostra
italia abbiamo bisogno di portare lo
spirito natalizio in giro anche se
ammetto che sono veramente beccato con
cui trieste ma che buco di culo è
non si vede ecco questo è di livello
rotto lapidario e perché quando arrivi
schiodi
[Musica]
spesso qui si ama il suo del puchoz di
tutto per arrivare ci sono tutte
macchine noi no non volevamo prendere
dobbiamo farci appelli perché guardate
piccola è così che la nato il merlo
digitali posso dirla alla rosa falegname
contratta milano
iniziano fin da piccoli come gli
stambecchi con il carbonio nero questo
quadro sono e chiudiamo in europa si è
un'idea se non erro questo è uno dei
rosari più grandi d'europa questo è uno
dei rosmarini grandi d europa con i più
grandi d'europa quello è il ruscone uno
dietro soli più grandi d europa migranti
che prova il posto estivo poi
soprattutto giocato dalla via crocetta
tutta notte lo sai che quella delusione
più grande d'europa no non più uno dei è
uno dei rosoni più grandi d'europa
questo alle mie spalle d'europa è uno
dei rosoni più grandi
ma quello no quello lì
[Musica]
uno dei più grandi d'europa
ma il campanile più potente d'europa e
si sentono già rica
[Musica]
che risolvono di 32
castello di san giusto è più un
castellitto
e lo dissi che mi ricordi quella ragazza
del met si gira e balla
fantaghirò o 45 e quando lei arriva al
posto in cui c'è il castello tv così e
ci mette il castello in mezzo e poi
castello risorge era proprio una merda
fantaghirò mamma mia ben riusciti
davanti agli o capolavoro italiano dare
abbassa che dobbiamo parlare di
calcio e una vista pazzesca da occhio o
che vanno cucina niente
oddio è morto
ti è piaciuto il castello manu ecco
questo è un posto invece un po
agghiacciante perché si ricorrerà
attorno qua è già pieno di pietre
tombe non so forse commemorative dietro
c'è questo monumento ai martiri delle
foibe che praticamente gli ebrei in
italia venivano portati in questa
risiera di san sabba prima di andare ad
auschwitz e quando auschwitz piano
vengono uccisi direttamente re
[Musica]
passando a caso sono reso conto che
questa è la casa della valle di umberto
saba giuseppe abito dal 1887 al 1921
sono molti di più
umberto saba e diventa totale e grazie
anche a giuseppa diciamo che comunque se
per trovare il natale siamo dovuti
arrivare di fronte a una vetrina di un
negozio a trieste abbiamo sbagliato
qualcosa
ho un piccolo dubbio per tutte quante le
persone che il solo di trieste opere
saranno mai questo qui dietro di me è il
ponte rosso ma perché bianco e perché
così basso
quello dell'unghia e lo scioglimento dei
ghiacciai
vergognato forse rosso per qualcosa di
sangue però sul ponte rosso c'è una
statua importantissime dobbiamo vedere
geni commento ragazzi questa qui è la
statua di james joyce perché james joyce
ha iniziato il suo ulisse qua a trieste
infatti una città molto legata alla
letteratura e alla scrittura e alla
lettura la mia anima è a trieste lettera
a nora 7 ottobre 1909 è bravo james una
chance
ti piace il ponte rosso
sono fusione di trieste mib a tumulo
però scoperto che trieste la patria del
caffè non è napoli
allora ma è la parte del cartello in
redazione
morbido sia napoli e per bontà credo sia
napoli tra il 50 ma tema col calore
meglio quello di napoli
parole aveva fatto una fatica inutile
l'unico buono in quanto
mi trovo più interessante l'orso dino di
cioccolato avete notato quanto vanno a
mille busiello veramente una scena
orribile ho visto la mossa più buona
intanto sempre a trattare meglio questo
è quello di napoli andammo in slovenia
per con visto dista 10 km d'acqua vai
[Applauso]
abbiamo già avanzato
[Musica]
stavo andando al castello di miramare e
ancora non siamo andati in slovenia con
il sottofondo musicale per favore
[Musica]
stella amore
che stella ma castello a mare
castellammare
castell amore
[Risate]
castello a mare
castell amore
io non so voi ma credo di aver trovato
il mio posto preferito a trieste dietro
a una riserva naturale un parco
bellissimo
che serve dire altro vuoi mettere
rispetto al cappellino ma dove spuntato
questo ma noi c'è solo un problema che
questo
mi sta facendo pisciare sotto che ve ne
pare
[Applauso]
quando si
attivano a fare un giro per infatti i
miei
[Applauso]
guglielmo è sparito dove sei piscione
abbiamo la star è visto nei fatti vedere
sera è fisso nei fatti vedere biscione
la cosa che ci sta osservando come lo
chiamò ti sei perso guglielmo non ci
credo ormai diventato un horror uscenti
aspetta proviamo a farci sentire lo
striscione
ci senti
manor telefono ci devi sentire al vivo
ma è lui
eccolo dove
non è che ti sei allontanato tanto
perché per motivi per ovvi motivi non
sembra comunque ho fatto un giochi
andiamo in slovenia
ragazzi siamo al mio
ok ok
si abbina
[Musica]
è un orrendo di fame abbiamo ordinato un
sacco di cose tipiche tutti quanti devo
perso birra tranne giuda
[Musica]
non è più
presto la città del prosciutto cotto a
rischio lo fanno senza divina senza
niente proviamolo eppure di tutto il
resto però direi buono
questo con le cipolle e non so cosa sia
e follia la scarpetta tipicamente romana
ma se non scarpetti curabile non sei
presenze nessun
ministro
buono ma non solo un grande cambiamento
sia una grande partita all'inizio del
rom stock a fare un giro alla goccia
ragazzi
che successo ci sono cinque reali siti
cinque
persone che non ha visto però
guglielmo è un artista completo riesce
ad affrettare di riprendiamo il cibo per
lavare la prima carta marchi capisce
quanti mostruoso
[Musica]
che dici mano
no prima però stagista di quello che
provarli
tutto favore di magni sono
pure noi
perché mi ha dato una botta al cucchiaio
per farla tornare in genere trucco
non andiamo a dormire enrico faccio più
soft morto ed è così che questa puntata
del blog ma finisce qui senza averci
lasciato nulla se non un leggero senso
di mena nausea e malessere per questo
gruppo di falliti
la morale di questo breve video è simile
a quelle della vita non c'è a meno che
non ti sforzi non mi trovi una da solo
[Risate]
per voi che avete avuto le palle di
resistere fino a questo punto grazie
ragazzi avete stomaco da vendere adesso
però uscite scopate divertitevi e se vi
va
[Risate]
parma
ora qui ancora
con natali un cazzo e al prossimo video
[Musica]